>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Pause ]
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Welcome back.
For those that do not know who
I am, my name's Nick Brown.
I'm one of the music specialists who
produces the concert series here.
Thank you all for being wonderful
concertgoers this afternoon
and braving the cold
and the security lines
and all that business.
It was such a pleasure
to have Anne-Marie
and Alban perform for
us this afternoon.
[ Applause ]
And the goal was just to have
a brief, informal conversation
and then we'll let the
audience ask some questions
because I'm sure they'd
rather talk [inaudible].
The first question I have
for you both is what inspired
the program selections today?
>> Alban Gerhardt: Well, actually
the program was designed for Europe
because we American pianist
and German cellist could do
[ inaudible ]
program.
So the original program
was actually instead
of the Britten it was the
Villa-Lobos sonata but actually
after looking, it looked very
good on paper, but when we started
or when I started looking
closer, I really didn't thought,
think it fit as well
to the other pieces.
So we kicked out the Villa-Lobos
since we had played the Britten
before, and we loved it so much,
I think it's one of the best pieces
of German music in the 20th century.
So we threw it in, and
Britten spoke English.
So at some point America was
England and whatever, so.
But.
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Well, no,
I was just going to add, you know,
it's always fun putting
programs together.
You try and think of
thematic elements
and connective tissue throughout the
program, but the other element of it
that I always like to pay attention
to is what really works musically.
And so when Alban and I, we went
back and forth and back and forth
and back and forth with
these programs by email,
and, you know, just discussed what
actually works back and forth.
"Bernstein Meditations" was a bit of
a stretch off the beaten path, and,
but I think in the
context of this program,
it actually works really well
after intuition when, you know,
everybody can kind
of just get absorbed
into Bernstein's world there.
So it was, you know, it was
this combination, I think,
of trying to have a somewhat
thematic program and also wanting
to play repertoire that worked.
OK.
>> Alban Gerhardt: Well,
actually, we say it's fun
to put together programs, but
you're talking more as pianist.
As a cellist, because
there is nothing, no fun.
We had to sometimes
put things together,
which might look [like] not work
as well because there is just
so little repertoire
compared to pianists.
I mean, with pianists, that's
sensational what you can do but -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Yeah -
>> Alban Gerhardt: We have nothing.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: So perhaps as
a follow-up to that, how do the both
of you approach programming
for chamber settings
that you're performing in
versus programming for, say,
a festival that you
might be involved in?
I know you have artistic
directorships that you,
how much of the programming
do you do for that,
and what's the difference
between your approach
for when you're performing
versus when you're just
programming for someone else?
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: I
don't think it's different.
You know, I just, whether it's
programming for recitals for Alban
and I have together or
programming for festival,
the only difference might
be in the festival context,
you have to just make sure
there's enough rehearsal time,
and you have to make sure
you're inviting musicians
who feel there's enough rehearsal
time to put the program together.
But, you know, it's all
about just presenting great,
compelling music really
when it comes down to it.
>> Alban Gerhardt: And
then at the end of the day,
it doesn't really matter.
If it makes any sense, I always,
when I put programs together,
I think of myself as the little
boy who loved to go to concerts
and hated to be bored
at the concert.
So I want to put program, I want to
put programs together where I could,
which I could enjoy
myself as a listener,
and my worst experience ever
was listening to all Bach suites
from the teacher I had
worked with when I was 11
or so, and I listened to them.
I hated, actually for the longest
time, I didn't like Bach afterwards
because he put me to sleep.
It was awful, and that's.
Don't ever play Bach suites
as boring as this time.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: On that note.
One question that just came
to mind is have you ever
in your touring career
noticed an audience
in a certain city evolve at all?
Like -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott:
Absolutely -
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
One decade to another -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Absolutely,
and one, you know, I'm a New Yorker
through and through, and
I'll always be a New Yorker.
So I'm blessed with a
great audience in New York.
They're great.
The Washington audience,
yes, they're great.
Hey, these are my people,
and I love --
I mean, the New York audience is
a little noisy, but I love them.
No, but they're, they
are passionate.
They say what they think and,
in fact, I'll tell you a really,
really quick little story
because this is just
so typical of a New York audience.
A violinist and I were
recording, doing a live recording
of a Poulenc violin sonata, and
the last movement is more violent
so it's very feisty, and comes
to this crashing chord,
and then a fermata.
So we're doing, we
tell the audience,
live audience we're doing
a recording, and, yet,
play the crashing chord,
silence, and the little lady
in the second row goes,
"Jesus Christ".
But, you know, I mean,
the Washington audience is another
incredibly intelligent cultured
audience, and I mean that because
I played down here so many years,
and I have a ton of
family down here.
But, you know, I have a case
where I, I'm artistic director
at a festival in Provo --
I mean in Vail, Colorado.
Tremendous festival, but people
weren't really loving the chamber
music as much as they needed
to love the chamber music,
and -- in my opinion.
So, you know, and I've
been there six years,
and I've seen a real evolution,
and one of the ways I found was
with just a couple of
key people, I would say,
it's the ones who would say, no.
I have no interest in chamber music.
I'd say, you know what, just
come and sit in on rehearsal.
Just be my guest.
Just come, sit ten minutes.
That's all, and one gentleman
in particular who came,
first day he sat ten minutes.
The next day he sat for an hour.
He started coming to
all the rehearsals,
and now he's a subscriber
[inaudible].
You know, so it's, I think,
sometimes it's our role to try
and -- help is the wrong word.
Try and turn people on, I guess, to
what it is we're so in love with,
and see that audience can evolve.
You know, I have a - Ida Kavafian,
a great, great colleague of mine.
She runs a festival in
Angel Fire, New Mexico.
So we always joke, it's the
musicians and the bears,
and she's been running this
thing for thirty years, I think.
She has cultivated an incredible
audience who come from all
over the country and all
over the local region
because they trust
Ida, and, you know.
So it's, I think it's possible,
like, to see audiences evolve.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Great.
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: [multiple
speakers] I was really wrong.
I'm sorry.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Do
you have an answer on that?
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: No?
>> Nicholas A. Brown: The final
question that I have for you relates
to the manuscripts that I heard
you got to peek at earlier,
and this being a unique
venue where we get
to put forth archival materials
that are the originals for many
of the works that are performed
here, how did that impact you as a,
as performers today, or did
that spark any new thoughts
for the performance?
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Fear.
No.
>> Alban Gerhardt: Well,
we didn't actually get
to see, we only saw the covers.
So that didn't change anything,
but actually I wanted to,
I had some open questions
about the Barber.
So I, we wanted to look at
some spots, but I'll be back
in May so then I'll visit.
Because most of the 20th century
and 21st century editions,
they're edited.
So with Mozart, Beethoven,
and Bach, we have urtexts now,
but 20th century, there's
often just, for me, a cellist,
Rostropovich putting his things
in there, and all over the place.
You don't even know anymore
what the composer wanted.
With Barber there's some things that
I think [inaudible] really the thing
that he wants that some
cellists try to improve,
and then you should never
let cellists improve.
I mean, only can get worse.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Do you
have any thoughts any that -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott:
I, I, it's always amazing
to see a composer's hand and
how they wrote, you know,
because they vary so much.
All I said when I looked
at the manuscripts was I'm
really happy I'm not performing
from manuscripts.
Because they can, depending
on the composer there,
can be all over the map.
It can be, I would have definitely
had classes on the [inaudible].
>> Nicholas A. Brown: I have another
question before we turn it over.
How did you two start
working together?
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Should I
tell you or [do] you want to tell?
>> Alban Gerhardt: Actually, it's,
it's only our second concert
ever I think, and we --
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: No.
>> Alban Gerhardt: Well.
No. Our second recital ever.
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Third.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: No.
>> Anne-Marie McDermott:
Oh, OK, fine, second -
>> Alban Gerhardt: We played
single pieces here and there -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Oh, OK -
>> Alban Gerhardt:
But we never play.
So, and that's actually ages ago.
I mean, the first recital
was in October last year,
and now this number two,
but that we collaborated --
-- in festival, that
was '94, '95, '96.
I lived in New York, and I was part
of this young concert artist thing,
which you had visited earlier on,
and you're still involved with them.
So that's how we met.
We met at Spoleto Festival,
and we became friends.
We lived five blocks away.
I lived 114.
You lived 108, no.
Right across from Absolute Bagels.
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Yes.
>> Alban Gerhardt: And, and then
I didn't cross, we didn't meet
that often because you
were never there, but --
-- but, actually, we had
such great pizza parties,
and my first Jim Carrey
movie I watched with you is.
I managed to get you out
of your unhealthy marriage.
And you got a great husband also.
I had to twist your arm.
We were actually very close,
and then I moved away,
then we lost touch, actually.
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Yeah.
Yeah. It's, you know, I just want
to add that it's, you know, the --
we met during very formative years
at Spoleto Festival
down in Charleston, and.
[Inaudible] no, I was just
four or five, and, you know,
but you know what's
amazing is even when,
with some of greatest
colleagues back then,
we totally instantaneously clicked
when we were playing together, and,
in fact, we did the Britten
sonata way back then.
And then, you know, life happens,
and you go, and Alban, how dare him,
he left New York, and, you know.
So we both went on, and we've been
having our careers, and all of this,
and then, you know, we reconnected,
and then we thought, you know what,
this is just too good a
partnership when we play together.
Just so you know immediately
when you work with somebody,
it's just very natural and very
inspiring for us to do this.
So now it's our intention
we'll be doing more.
We're doing a couple of concerts
in Europe end of next week.
>> Alban Gerhardt:
We're doing a couple
of concerts next week,
but not in America.
That's good.
We leave this country
with our garbage.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Your American repertoire.
I'd love to open it up
to the audience now.
If you could just raise your
hand, and my colleague, Solomon,
will come to you with a microphone.
Yes, young lady in the salmon, peach
colored bright thing in the back.
>> Alban Gerhardt: It's not peach.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
You know, whatever.
>> Well, what made
you, what made you,
what inspired you to play the music?
>> Anne-Marie McDermott:
Well, I -- how old are you?
>> Seven.
>> Anne-Marie McDermott:
You're seven.
So when I was about five, my
mother took me to a concert.
I don't remember who was
playing, but it was a concerto.
So it was the piano soloist
in front of an orchestra,
and there was a big spotlight
on the piano and the soloist,
and that hugely impacted
me because I thought
that was the most glamorous,
powerful thing I'd ever seen.
And so it challenged me, and
then I started, I just was hungry
to play the piano, and --
So that was really the first
key thing was just the sound
of the piano, and what incredible
sounds the piano can make.
[Inaudible] I don't
even remember the piece.
I just remember the
spotlight on the piano.
>> Alban Gerhardt: So you care more
about the spotlight than the music.
[ Laughter ]
Well, what my parents -- your
parents weren't musicians.
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: No, no -
>> Alban Gerhardt: So I, but
my parents were musicians.
I didn't know there's another
profession than musician.
So it was quite boring.
I listened to music all
my life, and I didn't know
or could do anything else,
and I was a bit nerdy, and I still
am, but I was even more nerdy than.
I never left home.
I just played generally the
piano, and with a, oh, what is it.
These little things, these
blue things with white hands.
Just Schlümpfe.
>> Smurfs -
>> Alban Gerhardt: Smurfs.
Yeah. I [inaudible] Smurfs.
Cello, piano, and Smurf.
And I went to concerts a lot.
So actually I love
going to concerts.
I still do, but when I
was little, once my --
I got punished because I
hadn't done the homework,
and my parents punished me by not
taking me to a Bruckner symphony.
I mean, normal kids get punished by
being taken to a Bruckner symphony.
[ Background Discussion
and Laughter ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
We'll come around in a sec.
>> You're
[ inaudible ]
on Brittens, and thank
you so much for that.
It was beautiful.
Does keeping the music down on
the piano help you see better?
Is that -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Yeah.
The reason I have the music flat
[inaudible] piano, I've done this
for years and years is I can hear
the sound of the piano better.
The music rack locks sound,
and so I've gotten accustomed
to reading the music.
When I get up for music, I know
it very well, or I'd better.
And so I actually, it's good for my
line of sight seeing it like that.
It's just kind of difficult on the
page turners, but I try and be nice,
but that's the whole reason.
The page turner today
was phenomenal.
She was incredible.
She left.
>> Can you tell us about your
cello, the history of your cello,
and what you appreciate about it?
What's challenging about it?
>> Alban Gerhardt: It's
a very bad history.
One of my -- the cello I had before
was stolen, and then I was looking
for a year, and in 2005, I -- some
gallerist offered me this thing
or [inaudible] purchase
another from a dealer.
Very complicated.
So I played on it, and it didn't
sound great, but I played,
I think I played the Schumann
concerto on it and actually it did,
it was difficult to play,
but it did fill the halls.
It was rather cheap,
and I bought it then.
It's Matteo Goffriller and my
-- everybody said don't buy it.
It's in a horrible shape,
and [inaudible] is very
big, like, oversize thing.
But my luthier, she
said - my violin maker,
she said she will do some work,
and it would only sound better.
And actually since then,
they've improved it now.
I'm very happy to have it.
It supposedly belonged
once to Mussolini,
which is not a good
thing, obviously.
So then he gave it to a friend,
his favorite poet, D'Annunzio,
but then to make up for bad commerce
Jewish cellists in Hamburg played
on it, I don't know the
name, and then it was sitting
in some basement for twenty years.
And the story is so bad
that probably it's true.
So, I mean, that Mussolini
story's bad,
and the gallerist didn't
strike me as a fascist.
So I guess, but I have
no proof of it.
And actually the other
day I was looking
at Wikipedia said the cello
belonged to Mussolini.
No, they cannot.
Well, because I want to know
what crap is written there,
and actually fifty percent what
was written, there was just wrong.
They had, so actually we cannot
trust wikipedia very interesting.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Actually,
I always thought it was.
OK. Anyway, so that's
the story of the cello,
and the maker is Matteo
Goffriller from Venice.
So you want to say
something to the piano?
>> Anne-Marie McDermott:
Oh, you know us pianists,
we have to be chameleons
and always play
on different instruments and adapt.
This happens to be
a beautiful piano.
So I got spoiled today.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: I'm
going to quote you on that.
Thank you.
>> First of all, thank you
for a sensational concert.
You play the Prokofiev
with such passion.
Do you play a lot of
Prokofiev pieces?
>> Alban Gerhardt: Well,
actually you're the -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: I'm rather
Prokofiev obsessed, and I, you know,
did, for, back several years,
I was touring with the whole
Prokofiev sonata cycle --
three recitals, all nine Prokofiev
sonatas, and then I recorded them.
And I just have a real
relationship with Prokofiev.
There's so much I'm
so challenged by,
but I think this particular
work, the march from "The Love
for Three Oranges", it was actually
written in this country in Chicago,
I believe, and sponsored by Sunkist.
And so that's true actually.
And, but it is just a perfect
encore, and I can tell you really,
I don't know whether I would
ever put another cellist
on the planet who can play it.
>> Alban Gerhardt: What?
It's not difficult, I
just screwed up, but -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: But
the way he plays it, it's a,
it's the perfect, it really is
such a great encore, you know,
because after a long program it's
just, like, an exclamation point.
>> Alban Gerhardt: Yeah, I was
just being polite handing you
the microphone.
It was my question, though I
have no relation with Prokofiev.
Actually, I think he is one
of my favorite Russian --
favorite Russian composer.
I like him better than
Shostakovich --
I think of it as more variety to it.
Shostakovich is just always
depressed and Prokofiev --
I don't know -- it's very
childlike music, I mean,
for every child should listen to
as much Prokofiev as possible.
>> Yeah -
>> Alban Gerhardt: But, like,
I think I was 23 when I heard
for the first time "Cinderella" by
Prokofiev, and I couldn't believe
that it took so long because it's
such a fantastic work, or "Romeo
and Juliet", and, obviously,
I play the cello stuff
that we just did the sonata
and the cello symphony,
and there's the cello sonatina,
which I have never played.
Is that a good piece, Bob?
You know, [inaudible].
It's good.
So next time I'm playing.
But, no, I love Prokofiev very much.
My -- I have a little boy.
He's two and a half, and he
loves "Peter and the Wolf".
He can sing all the subjects
and it's pretty cute.
Actually quite in tune.
It's amazing.
I sometimes try to live
up to his intonation.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: One
second for the microphone.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Could you comment, could you --
>> Nicholas A. Brown: It's on -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: You're on -
>> Could you comment on
the Gershwin as a pianist,
and now I'm sure you've
played the preludes
in their original form,
and the arrangements.
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Yeah.
The -- I love playing Gershwin, and,
you know, it makes me feel cool,
and I'm not cool, and it makes
me feel like I can play jazz,
and actually my, one of
my cousins is here today,
and he's a brilliant jazz pianist,
and I'm envious because I'm not.
But a Gershwin, because everything's
written out, makes you feel
like you have some of that.
And so it's always
weird when you play,
I play [inaudible] for solo piano.
It's always weird, then, when you
play a transcription of it and all,
so much fun stuff is taken out
and given to a string player.
So, I mean, it's definitely
a little, I'm playing,
and I'm restraining myself.
Like, darn, why does he have
that line, but, you know.
I actually have never played
the three preludes with cello.
Are you the only cellist on
the planet who does that?
>> Alban Gerhardt: Well,
I've never played either.
That was the first time -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: I
mean, that's an undertaking
to play those three preludes on
the cello, to tell you the truth.
Yeah.
>> Alban Gerhardt: But you did
it with violin quite a lot -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: I've
done it a lot with violin yeah.
It's best, best really in
its pure form -- solo piano.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
I think we have time
for a couple more questions.
Alban, I was wondering when you
first encountered the Britten,
you played it so spectacularly-how
you came to it?
Question was when Alban first
came to the Britten sonata.
>> Alban Gerhardt: Well,
actually I was going to use
that as a justification for
having written an ordinary program
because the first time I heard
it I think was in a master class
with Rostropovich in
Washington in 1993.
I had. Well, I never
heard it live maybe
on CD, but I couldn't remember.
In that master class, it
struck me as a great piece
for the first time
somehow, and I don't know
when I started learning
it, but I think it's one
of the greatest pieces
for piano and cello
in the 20th century
because it's so equal.
Just such an incredible, you can
sense the partnership of Britten
and Rostropovich there
because they were equals,
and then both instruments are
completely on the same level.
There's no accompaniment of
anything, and it's so much variety.
You can almost use every single
of the movements as an encore.
I've done actually, even
the slow movement I've used
as an encore once.
I mean, if the piece is
not the problem, obviously.
But number two, four, five
work beautifully as encores.
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Yup.
>> Alban Gerhardt: So that's, yeah.
Otherwise, I have, well, I've always
found it very difficult memory wise.
I don't know why, but Britten
somehow, it's not very logical.
Like, the suites, it took
me forever to remember them
because there's no
real pattern behind -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Yeah -
>> Alban Gerhardt: It's almost
improvised, and the sonata has a lot
of improvisatory elements as well.
So, but I love it.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Do you know the anecdote
about Britten humming the thing
to Rostropovich over dinner?
So, apparently, if you go
read some of the literature
about this piece coming together,
when Rostropovich got to Aldeburgh
to do the first performance,
and they were rehearsing,
there was some tension
going back and forth
because Rostropovich wasn't giving
Britten what he wanted in some
of the moments, and Britten
didn't want to anger him.
So he wouldn't say
anything, but at dinner later,
Britten started humming this
thing how he wanted it played,
and Rostropovich got it,
and he played it that way,
and he didn't even say anything.
>> Alban Gerhardt: But
as cute as that story is,
it's incredibly telling,
and it's exactly what I say.
Because Rostropovich
did whatever he wanted.
For me, it was Rostropovich-[he] is
the greatest cellist of all times,
but you should not listen, you
should not take his Britten
of playing as an example
of how it should be done.
Because I'm sure Britten
didn't tell him anything.
This little humming story,
that's cute, but he, and, like,
with the cello symphony,
he's ignoring strongly what Britten
wrote, and actually it doesn't work.
I mean, I don't, I, 95 percent of
the things Rostropovich recorded
and played, I love,
but his Britten -- eh.
It's too Russian.
He doesn't get the British
sense of humor that, yeah.
I don't know, and so I can't
meet the part of the story
that Britten dared to tell
Rostropovich what, yes.
But then later because Rostropovich
understood [inaudible] down here,
but, again, to take it as an
example would be quite bad
because just the fact
that Rostropovich worked
with just the [inaudible]
does not mean
that Rostropovich was doing
what Shostakovich wanted.
Shostakovich was spineless
little paranoid person,
and he would not stand up and tell
this great charismatic person how
to play the piece.
He was happy that such a fantastic
cellist was taking his stuff on.
I mean, I played pieces
by composers.
They hardly ever tell you what to
do unless you ask, but I never ask.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Great.
>> Alban Gerhardt: But
there's a cute story, which -
is there a Rostropovich
museum here or something?
Or some -
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
I'm not aware of one.
Does anyone know?
No. Well, he had the connection
to the Kennedy Center -
>> Alban Gerhardt: I know, but it's.
I've been told in some place here
there's a little handkerchief.
Britten wrote something on it.
Britten and Rostropovich
were playing a program here.
Do you know the story?
And they played somewhere in
North England forever to stay
with a friend of Britten's, duke,
and Shostakovich was
completely excited
because we don't have
dukes in Russia anymore.
So I need to practice
my bow for the duke.
So at every little stop they took
to go to the bathroom or to eat,
Rostropovich was taking
a bow, and Britten was,
he told it for the first time.
No, don't have to do anything.
We're in England.
So, no, no, I have to.
You don't understand.
Britten got more and
more embarrassed,
the bigger the bows became.
At some point, Britten
said, OK, anything you want.
Just don't bow, and
Rostropovich says OK.
Write me something for cello.
OK, OK. No, no, no.
You have to write it now,
and then Britten wrote "Me,
Benjamin Britten...I confirmed
that I will write something
for Mstislav Rostropovich.
And this thing where he
wrote it on the [inaudible]
but maybe now it's somewhere else.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Maybe it's,
if anyone knows some private dealers
around [multiple speakers].
>> Alban Gerhardt:
You should go there -
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
That's a great story -
>> Alban Gerhardt: No.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
Last question.
You can just yell it out, and
I'll repeat it if you'd like.
>> You just played so
well off each other,
and I'm wondering how much
you actually discuss the music
and how much is just the result of
your rehearsals and [inaudible].
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Question
was how much they discuss
about the music in
rehearsals, or does the,
do the things come
together organically.
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: I think,
you know, there are certain,
at least in my career and life,
there are certain colleagues
who I've met where words really
just don't matter as much
as just playing together, and,
you know, I feel when Alban
and I play together, we're as --
Of course, we rehearse, and we
discuss things, but when we get
on stage, we're really just
in this world right here having
a conversation truly, and it's,
there's a lot of trust that has to.
You know, I think it
probably doesn't hurt
that we've known each
other for such a long time,
but it's also this musical trust of
where is he going to play the note
or timings of things because
we definitely veer off
of what we discuss when we rehearse.
And, I mean, for me, it's,
it really is all about,
the music is the language.
That's the language that we speak.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Imagine
rehearsals are like this.
>> Alban Gerhardt: You're too PC.
>> Anne-Marie McDermott:
I'm too PC -
>> Alban Gerhardt: Come on -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott:
Oh, my God -
>> Alban Gerhardt: We
didn't discuss anything.
Like, if you take the
time of practicing.
Like, when we did the Britten for
the first time, I remember I went
to your apartment,
and we had one hour.
So we didn't have time to discuss.
We played, and then we played
again then hardly played again,
and then the concert -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Yeah -
>> Alban Gerhardt:
So actually words,
probably two or three percent -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Yup -
>> Alban Gerhardt: If at all -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Yeah -
>> Alban Gerhardt:
The rehearsal time -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Yup -
>> Alban Gerhardt: So it's playing
and then something
doesn't work, we said OK,
backup 20 bars, do it again,
and then it falls into place.
So we don't even have
to point so much out -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Yeah -
>> Alban Gerhardt: And the --
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Yeah.
>> Alban Gerhardt: And
sometimes when you have
to discuss, it doesn't work -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Yup -
>> Alban Gerhardt: I
made the experience -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott:
Oh, many times.
I've. No, I found out many times
that you're in a rehearsal,
and everything needs to be
analyzed and overanalyzed.
Everybody gets -- starts second
guessing what they're doing
and second guessing the
most important thing,
which is it's about
the music or the words,
and not to sound all
philosophical, but it's true.
That music are, that's the
language that we speak,
and so that's what we're doing
is speaking that language
so problems will resolve in the
course of our playing together as -
>> Alban Gerhardt:
There's too much agreement
on what to do with things -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Yeah.
>> Alban Gerhardt: It becomes
not spontaneous anymore -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Oh, yeah -
>> Alban Gerhardt: We say do
this here, and this there,
and there, and here we go.
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: Well,
I would say that we greatly
challenge each other in,
when we're playing together.
Alban's constantly surprising
me by doing something.
Oh, oh, oh, OK, and then,
you know, I try and -
>> Alban Gerhardt: I
surprise myself and -
>> Anne-Marie McDermott: You
surprise yourself, and, but I try
and return the favor, but, you
know, that's what you want.
You know, that's the point of live
concerts as opposed to recording.
It is live concerts, it's,
if we were in this space
with you all having a living
conversation with the music
in this moment of time at
2:00 on a Saturday afternoon.
So when we play next week in
Manchester, it's not going
to be the same thing, and, or
Germany or whatever it is, right.
OK.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Wonderful.
Well, thank you, Anne-Marie
and Alban,
for spending time with
us this afternoon.
We appreciate it.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc dot gov.